it's a little bit tricky because the
width is defined at 640 pixels but the
max width is set to 100% the max width
actually overrides the width which means
that the owl image will be kept
contained within its container
so this one is responsive looking at the
logo we see its width is 125 pixels this
is actually fine because 125 pixels is
pretty much smaller than any device so
this one will actually work well and be
responsive this one's actually a little
dangerous even though the width isn't
really that large the viewport width on
some of the smaller devices can be as
low as 320 pixels which means that a box
with the width of 350 pixels could cause
some horizontal scrolling so this one
isn't responsive and finally with the
city div we see its width is a hundred
percent which means it's always relative
and will be responsive